what i want to talk about in this video
is the liter the liter let me write this
down
the liter and the liter is a unit for
measuring fluid volume so how much space
does a fluid take up
so what does one liter look like
well one of these milk bottles
is a liter and you're most typically
going to think about a liter in your
everyday life when you're buying some
type of beverages milk or water in fact
next time you go to the grocery store
see a lot of the a lot of the bottles
you get they might be exactly one liter
some of the soda bottles are two liters
but this right over here is one
one liter and we'd write a capital l for
short that's one liter and so there's
six liters in total in this little
carrying case but each of these milk
bottles is one liter
so that's a liter but what if we want to
go to really small volumes of water well
if we want to go to really small volumes
of water we normally talk about
milliliters
milliliters let me write this down
milli
milliliters actually let me write it
this way let me write milli in another
color
milly
milliliters
so it's a milli
liter
and a milliliter a milli is a prefix
that you'll see a lot when you're using
units and that means one one thousandth
of a liter so this means one
one thousandth
one one thousandth of
of a
of a liter and the notation for
milliliter is a lowercase m and an
uppercase l milliliter another way to
think about it it would take 1 000
milliliters to get to 1 liter
so what does a milliliter look like well
if you imagine these medicine droppers a
milliliter would be about that high on
one of those medicine droppers and a lot
of these medicine droppers actually will
have a milliliter actually they'll have
up to five milliliters marked off but a
milliliter would be about that much
or if you were to take a teaspoon from
your cabinet in your kitchen and you
were to scoop out a teaspoon of water
that so this one over here is going to
be about one
milliliter
and a teaspoon of fluid that's going to
be about five
that's going to be about five
milliliters so another way to think
about it is you would have to take a
thousand of these drops to fill one of
these one of these bottles of milk a
thousand milliliters to get to one liter
or you would have to do let's see five
you'd have to put five sorry you'd have
to do 200 teaspoons of say milk to fill
up this entire thing because each of
them is 5 milliliters 200 times 5
milliliters you're going to have a
thousand milliliters which is 1 liter
let me write this down
this right over here this is 1 liter
which is the same thing as 1 000
1000 milliliters
now what if we go to what if we go to
things that are much larger what if we
go to things that are much larger than
the scale of a
of a jar of milk say a swimming pool and
this right over here this is a picture
of a olympic-sized swimming pool which
is for the most part the largest pools
well there are some larger pools at some
fancy hotels and things but they're very
large pools so what do you think would
be if if one milk
bottle has a one like this has a fluid
volume of one liter what do you think
about a whole swimming pool
well actually a swimming pool like this
if it is 25 meters wide and 50 meters
long and two meters deep it actually
would have a fluid volume are you ready
for this it would have a fluid volume of
2.5 million 2.5 million liters
so if you fill this up with milk you
could use that milk to fill up 2.5
million of these bottles so that's just
an appreciation for just how much fluid
it would take to fill up at least a big
swimming pool like this an olympic-sized
swimming pool a swimming pool that you
might more typically see at someone's
house who isn't you know that doesn't
have an olympic-sized swimming pool so
kind of a house-sized swimming pool is
still going to be it's not unusual to
see one that'll be more than 100
100 000
100 000 liters so once again are you
thinking about teaspoons or or drops of
from a dropper you're thinking in the
milliliter range if you're thinking
about the type of something that you
might drink in a day or that your family
might drink over say a week you're
thinking in really the leader range and
if you're thinking about how much how
much fluid it would take to fill a
swimming pool now you're talking in the
tens of thousands or hundreds of
thousands or even millions of liter
range